Oh should I act normal oh it's a video I
get a feeling there's gonna be a riot I
don't because welcome to another episode
of safe space it is good to be here very
excited episode you know I've been doing
this rancho for a while I decided I just
wanted I like ranting so I decided to a
rancho for a little while and i like it
but i also like having some people in
work and just like one-on-one talk so i
decided like every like four sho i'll
bring somebody in and i decided it was
time to have her back in the saddle
because you know we were so intertwined
for so long and then like over like the
last two years we've kind of just did
our own thing when her own way and i
just wanted to catch up and see how
she's doing and uh cuz i know she's
doing some great stuff ah please welcome
Vicki pezza everybody hello Sam how are
you Vikki great how are you I'm so happy
you're back it's been a long time since
we podcast and uh you know I've once a
while you'll pop up on my Twitter you'll
say something to me or I'll say
something you on twitter and it just
made me think about the old times how we
didn't talk and how like probably just
got weird and I'm most likely at fault
as much as anybody Anderson okay and I'm
not against that I'm not against that
and I am ready to hear it oh my god how
exciting okay and it's totally cool and
I'm ruling to do ahh real quick before I
get anything I am going to be at the
Chicago comedy bar this friday saturday
this thursday friday and saturday so
come out and uh big announcement tonight
show in Vegas we decided cut the cord
and that will not be happening next week
we're just going to cut it
then figure out what I want to do next
year at another casino so thank you for
everybody who came out in support it was
a wonderful run [__] be crazy so [__]
happened so we are back in like I said
Vicki yah welcome back it's good to see
you thanks I'm happy you're here you
look wonderful you seem like you've
changed a little bit really like you
don't wear the glasses anymore did you
ever wear the glasses I feel like I did
wear glasses I usually have green
contacts okay clear one and your hair's
a little different right along yes yeah
wearing a different as anything else
changed since we was have been two years
Jesus I don't think so nothing Jake must
say I'm still a huge pothead that's
right basically do in chiril dude yeah
living simmy nothing but podcasts you
have more dogs now I double downed on
dogs since last time you have two dogs
have two dogs to both pit bull mixes
that's great well I've been thinking
about doing charities for pit bulls I
think that'd be a great idea I think
that pit bulls are the most under
misunderstood breed out there that
there's some [__] that get hold of
pit bulls because there's this whole
lore that comes with them that they're
like these bad ass dudes and the real at
the end of the day they just want to be
cut they just want to cuddle and their
little babies and they want to be loved
like any other organism in the world and
they only get turned into bad things by
bad people who beat them and make them
do bad things I agree with that I got
out of two of them one of them's like
adorable sweet the sweetest dog ever
that's a weimaraner pitbull the Boston
Terrier pitbull a little bit more like
food has food aggression hates little
kids like I don't know we're gonna do
can't have little kids with that dog dog
hates little kid hates little kids is
afraid of little kids I look he also has
a crooked tail so there might have been
an incident we regret they grabbed him I
know yeah there might have been an
incident yeah maybe with a sliding glass
door yeah she seemed to know what the
door was right away okay is outside so
but I think it's more the Boston
terrier in him because he's pure terrier
so I think that this is just what if you
gave a Boston Terrier the strength of a
pit bull then you get Cody yeah adri's a
little angel cheese moment like the big
chest the big thick like that Kurt Angle
looking at no I mean no I get it we're
talking about like she has the look and
then i have this mutant who's like a
little bit of an [__] but i love them
both so much yeah it's so interesting
when they have personalities and you
don't realize that about a dog until you
get a dog look and I'm sure it's the
same thing with cats I've been thinking
about getting a cat I just want a cat
I've never owned a cat and I think
Pollyanna is the closest thing to a cat
Pollyanna is a [__] talking dog so smart
and it's so funny because I was talking
about the sudden stage the other day
about how Pollyanna is so smart but yes
she does dumb [__] to you know like like
chill or like like get on my door of my
car and push on the window and just
stare at me as she pushes down the
window like I don't need you and she
like figure out ways to open the door
and walk out and I look on she almost
like she's moonwalking flipping me off
and she does it but then we get a
balloon and she like freaks out like
bueno de rider from stranger things like
seeing a [__] monster it's like it's
a balloon mensa you [__] oh hey so it's
so weird but I'm a big dog / I've been
why i disguised charity that kind of
helps pitbull I just wish like people
would stop breeding them and turn them
in the fight I don't understand how
people are cool with hurting other
things no I don't get it now I know that
you are what does that sound oh there's
some going on doesn't breaking there's a
break into fire word shootings doors
locked raise the door lock in case of
shooting some [__] up nobody cares
button you're not gonna try locking to
my or should we just go out like this
yeah why we do what we love podcaster um
so yeah so now you're working on to
podcasts I know you went on to oh ah
point versus point yes also on this
network okay so that can you break that
down for them for anybody who doesn't
listen to they might want
we both have a mutual love of uh of
Gareth Reynolds full full homo yeah Elmo
and we'll get into that too yes its
Gareth Reynolds and Evan man and we
market it or just talk about it as if
it's a real debate news show which it's
not at all we use real news stories but
it's just evan is a somewhat reasonable
person and Garrett's character is just a
[__] maniac who doesn't know any
facts who's just like like right now
with the election the whole show
switched cuz the whole time it's been
like two years agera three and like [__]
obama and now like Evans characters like
devastated and Garrett's like we're in
the locker rooms in the locker room baby
yeah so it's only 30 minutes to so it's
a nice short walk people like those
podcasts nice and quick I think there's
some illusion going on there like
everything has to be the joe rogan
experience of like three hours yeah I
know like hey I amazing how many people
go oh did you know I listened to you I
do drywall you know the race notion that
you gotta fill up a whole ship to dry
walling but i think people like through
i try to do this podcast at three
minutes 30 minutes it usually goes 45
but i like doing a special even that's
good like an hour or under an hour i
think at this point I feel like the
people like Rogan or kevin smith or
corolla anyone that goes long they've
been doing that for like seven years
eight years if you're trying to get Pete
like like people to listen to a new show
like they have their schedule so you got
to make something nice and consumable
that it can insert into their life every
week that's the biggest thing I try to
tell like new people doing podcasts
first of all I say don't even start a
podcast start a YouTube channel like a
video blog that you can like pull the
audio maybe put it out as a podcast
because I just feel like good i get
there is like an oversaturation going on
and but what i tell them it's like dude
first of all you gotta come up with
something that you see yourself doing
so I don't know and then you gotta come
up with something that is like executed
like maybe do 10 of them before you
start putting them out today okay we got
it now we start putting out because it
is such an oversaturated market like
punch-drunk was like the first of the
comedian's doing sports talk yeah then
came fired a kid and that just blew up
and now jim norton and matt sarah has
even gone bigger than that so it's like
you're up against famous people now
you're up against everything it's like
such an oversaturated and you're way
more into the podcast scene than I am um
yeah I guess so I'm 100 I like I've
lately been like I do my thing I listen
to a couple sports podcast and I could I
I i watch Rogen stuff on YouTube when
I'm like do another I'll go down that
rabbit hole if it's about something I
want right here yeah but I'm really not
into like listening the pocket unless a
couple sports podcast yeah sometimes I
almost always listen to this show tell
them Steve Dave that's the main show
like that's a show work like I'm gonna
listen every week I'm gonna listen to
every single episode and of course the
ones i make like you know i have to show
you work on that podcast too um I don't
work on it but I use all four years I
make yeah like I make wraps for them
which is weird you have any examples of
your raps we could hear I mean like oh
maybe on my phone I'm not gonna like
start no can you play on your phone so
we could hear one all right um I could
pull one up I guess but that's like all
i all i really do for them and they're
in New Jersey anyway so like when I went
to New Jersey like I went on their show
is it somewhat based on the comic book
TV show the comic book store show it's
two of the guys from that Walt and Brian
Johnson and then it's one of the guys
cue from Impractical Jokers oh oh it's
like they're all friends at like they've
all worked at that time practical jokers
it a cue he has um yep yeah beard he
where's the Hat he's like I guess they
have a heavier set than some of the
other got lesser known of them or I
don't know why I feel like there's two
people that are two-faced that show the
dude who's kind of balding yeah and then
the one with the beard that always gets
set up to as kind of by the joke I've
only watched a couple episodes lately
there's two dudes with beards there's
one guy with glasses with a beard right
maybe Sal I don't know let's hear your
rap ok um I want to hear up like I just
play here yeah all right so wait the the
here's the setup to this all right so
like this is how it'll go they'll be
like we're gonna do an episode about
this theme can you make a rap about it
ok so this theme was like it's their
300th episode and they're gonna have a
contest where someone has to marry this
like second string character get em
steve-dave they call him he's just this
maniac this maniac that would want there
to be markets know Jersey is he a real
character as he goes he cares oh no he's
a real person that they just dubbed him
get him Steve Dave I think that was his
Twitter handle like he just kind of
inserted himself into the show which I
guess I did too he was out he was a
squatter he owned the website yes he
bought tell em steve-dave calm at the
very beginning and tried to sell it to
them like he was holding it ransom
somehow became like this character on
the show so they're like can you make a
rap about him getting married or like
like this is what we're gonna do so like
this is how I'll do it this one's almost
a little parody ish because I didn't
have to do like the I'd have to make
like the track or anything yeah and then
play these yeah they put them in the
episodes so like I'll set it up can you
hear it yes how long can you go like
this
meaning are you happy I wouldn't say I'm
happy happy I mean I'd like to have me
be a significant other but I think
that's what change you wouldn't be at
the bile dump no more it's all I
wouldn't be at the flea market all the
time and I am me yeah I think I don't
know I just don't go prostitution
thirteen percent that's me look I like
the podcast too but honey only could
actually marry this dude right yo can
you smell the romance wait that is what
do it that's the smell of horses politie
in light of 300 this is wat at st
history deck where can you throw the
bridal shower a minimum yes your wedding
if you let them then sell it on vamp
camp as thus marriage or get up ladies
who lined up for this bro race where all
the bachelorettes wanna see gillum's
whole face was wet when the goals get
his pole who forgets his mandela effects
or [__] I know meetup amitabh wanna
hump yah but how you gonna let this
bottle don't jump off yup and get him
Steve Dave what is wrong with you you
should be knee deep in [__] just by
knowing you get to know will then get
him listen to him trussed up you're not
supposed to whisper to him that's what's
really touched up okay I think you get
the point that is so good thank you I
was blown away thanks when she was on
their show they're like so how long have
you been rapping she's like I just do
this for you God like I just thought
it'd be funny is like why don't you put
on a rap album is good I'm going to I'm
going to next year really yeah yeah I'm
gonna the first one I'm gonna do is for
these guys cuz they're like you should
be selling these songs yeah and I'm i
already have six of them and I'm like
all right well after New Year's like
first quarter 2017 let me write a few
more let me release you should practice
going on stage wrapping these I know you
think I'm crazy that's a niche man
you rap about podcasting there's nerd
rap as big I don't know if you want
consider yourself nerd yeah but I mean
you're rapping about podcast I mean it's
done did you listen to the lyrics and
you didn't get any of them cuz it's such
inside nonsense thanks umezaki wood
breaking up with somebody and yeah it's
like all the inside jokes of like their
shadowed you should [__] totally tour
lon that yep I mean you're you're
editing skills are like [__] ninja at
this point yeah and that's cut with cuz
that's almost straight ghetto superstar
but I it's cut with closer like you know
don't don't so that's in there too and
at the end that song like more are you
making money off your editing now yes
you make bad yes really yes that's
[__] awesome good yeah so you're
doing the MMA podcast too though idea
yes yes so that came back around yes I
got it they called me three years later
three years later Frank Shamrock called
me and was that I thought it was a
mistake you know when you see somebody
called you and you're like though he
butt-dialed me Ronnie left a message and
he's like we have another idea for a
show Maura wants to do another podcast
he's he's about to start on WWE this
week is he doing boxing still yes that
guy he is never home do you under this
guy's life he's home like a day or two a
week and and inexplicably wants to
podcast on those days so like we
recorded his house and it's a him in
boss ruin I love bathroom me too Jesus
nicest guy in the world nicest guy in
the world um couldn't believe cuz him I
didn't know you know I knew more oh and
Frank um but yeah they call me up and
they're like we got money and I'm like
then I then I agree hahaha so it's yeah
that's pretty fun and now they just
split their show in half why oh um
they're not getting along oh no no um no
they they're both hosting both things it
was just too lengthy it would sometimes
there would be two hours sometimes it
would almost be three hours so they
broke the podcast apart we're now on
Mondays they
release all MMA and it's all combat
sports so it's like UFC WWE kickboxing
glory because he does glory to he
announces for showtime boxing so they
talk sports and now they released that
on monday and friday it's called combat
sports carousel bits on the same feed
then fridays they do ruin in Ranallo
which is now just like them talk about
movies I'm talking about what's what's
trending like just you know others that
ever that almost takes more editing yeah
don't start busting into song so then
like afterwards like I'll go find the
song and make it sound like they're
singing to the song law that's all so
yeah so now it's like but i really i
only post produced the friday one so now
it's like I don't even have to hear
about mmm look it's so bizarre don't
like MMA are you like 9 mm a person like
it i just i don't know about it the the
amount everyone else seems to but you
know in I i accidentally learn
everything about it you know just by
being around it but I wouldn't say like
it's not something like they'll always
like throw questions to me and stuff
about like movies tiep like I can tell
you who an actor is right but I i can't
give you my opinion on Audrey's gonna
win a fight and you know it's not even
appropriate even though I have
accidentally in my head predicted cuz a
lot of the fights it seems like since I
start the show have been upset yeah and
where I'm kind of like oh like like I
thought I did think Michael Bisping was
gonna win like you know where but like I
never said anything cuz everyone seemed
so convinced he wasn't gonna win or we
should say something bay they should
have your pics my pit yeah we should do
it just for fun did you know knowing
nothing do you ever go to the fight um
no no have you ever asked to go no no
never do you want to go I mean if they
were like do you want to go to one I
would yeah for sure but it's uh it's not
something I'm really like after I'd
really rather go to WWE to be honest why
don't you ask him there I never do yeah
but that's [__] yeah I know they do
a lot I think we go through life
sometimes not want to ask for like
favors and I feel like there's people
out there that all
do is ask for favors and they get chip
because they ask for favors right right
I just feel like dude you got any extra
tickets be like [__] yeah especially
since wrestling has made this insane
come back he just seems like it's way
bigger than it was like 10 years ago
yeah it absent flows like you know like
I was really into the old man ba dad bod
wrestling which was like sergeant
slaughter Iron Sheik all that [__] and
then it kind of went weird it's it's in
this weird homoerotic kind of [__]
fighting now where it's like shredded
gay shape dudes who love the [__]
just hump each other and like it's
gotten really gate like in Japan you
ever see something Japanese wrestling
it's like it's like dudes giving to
[__] dude shockers and it's just
[__] really so edgy yeah we're just
talking did I already talked about i noe
talked about before did I talk about I
don't talking about it on the era de
about how like the new edgy and comedy
is gay like I just I watch two dudes
like big-name comics talk about like
sucking dick on stage like and it's like
there I just don't know if you're in a
bubble though I feel like that's a a
Hollywood bubble may be like dude i'll
suck a [__] dick and it's my it was
so crazy cuz he started talking about
sucking dick and being called the n-word
and I used to have a great bit about me
banging this Mexican and she just called
me the n-word and either crowds would go
crazy or they turn on me and now it's
like I watch you feel like I am like
dude you never want to be the um what's
a trailblazer you want to be the guy
after the trail blaze right the ID
trailblazer usually gets [__] arrows
put it on dies of starvation it's your
fault hey dude this is a nice path we go
through here and you just get to where
you want to [__] go no scarlet fever
down there yeah what's this [__]
skeleton baby that's yeah that's you
should [__] ass for that I'm weird
really weird like that sometimes people
take me for being um ah like arrogant
I'm weird and you might have opinions on
this and I'm waiting
they're getting weird and I'm not saying
that I'm 107th but a lot of it is just I
have crippling social anxiety like I am
not cut like one reason why like I get
so crazy about the comedy store and like
getting spots there's because it's like
it's one of the few plates like I'm
really comfortable like I can hang out
there for like three hours and not wig
the [__] out yeah even like places like
the improv like I can't get out of there
quick enough and it's nothing against
anybody there they're wonderful people
but it's just like my body starts
getting [__] like shaking like low
like I start just like it's like it's
like a tuning fork but boom I just start
like it starts shaking i can't i'm not
comfortable so i get the [__] out and uh
and i don't like to bother people that's
like the point of the whole story is
like I don't want like so I don't ask
for any favors whereas I know there's
people out there they are constantly hey
hey hey hey watch and do it and like
yeah I'm sure they get turned down
ninety percent of time but it's that ten
percent that they get what they're
looking for yeah Steve Simone taught me
something and it's pretty good advice
which is uh sometimes you think people
are thinking exactly what you're
thinking yeah and you expect them to
offer or give you something cuz in your
head you deserve this this it's as
simple as asking yeah let somebody know
the way you feel are the things you want
and that's it in recovery they say it's
like such an obvious thing but it's not
in recovery they say ah never expect
somebody to honor a contract they never
sign right you're like I do this for you
you should do for me it doesn't
necessarily in a city of narcissism yes
where it's like you help somebody they
sometimes they'll appreciate the help
because they feel it's their manifest
destiny that they were going to AA get
it anyways like you gave them this
opportunity because they were so great
and this is them on their path to
greatness right right well my point is
you should ask yeah so I want to get
with this and I'm sure it's going to be
an interesting conversation and I wanted
to talk to you about a couple things and
that was I feel like there's a reason
I'm here and I don't know what it is oh
it wasn't there I know you think there's
something soon sir here I will tell you
this right it's just like you know it's
like we were really close for a long
time I feel like at the end of the
naughty show we were bumping heads a lot
yes I'm a lot of [__] and you know I
mean without you know I would like to
hear your side but you know I I got my
feelings hurt and you know I acted there
was parts of it where I acted stupid and
I'll be the first one to admit it but I
feel like we never had a conversation I
felt like the podcast we did in your
house was really weird and there was
some weird energy and that I did in and
I'm not happy it ended that way and like
I'm not afraid to him to be like okay I
did some dumb [__] and is and because
I've had a history of dumb [__] and I've
done dumb [__] my career is most likely
where it is because I do dumb [__] and
I'm happy with where I am in my life of
my career I get to do everything I want
to and I build my brands and stuff like
that and but when I look at like we're
maybe some other people are to be like
Oh that'd be nice but you know it is
what it is and probably from the direct
results of actions I've taken do you
ever miss doing the naughty show
honestly um sometimes because i don't
have a comparable outlet I don't feel
where it's something even if I talk on
ruin and ranallo that's not the same
dynamic their steering the ship in a
very different way in a very do there
they're the host I'm I'm there to press
record they're pulling me into their
conversation Erin I'm sure gets gets
that yeah yeah yeahs re chords but he's
allowed he feels free to talk whenever
he wants to right i don't feel free
right i try to restrain myself you tried
to hold back yeah okay I'm punch drunk
cuz i get her saying cuz
90 people in the room but whenever you
have something say but on this podcast
it's kind of like i pod cast session but
you don't want to talk if you know how
to die i'll just staring i'm happy to do
it I just I don't want to become the
focus of your show okay no I respect
that and I get that and you're and it's
like you know when you're in your head
rolling up here you know like that's the
job you're doing is the engineering
where it's like you know you're not
rolling up with topics you want to talk
about that that's what I'm saying it's a
totally different different diners and
even on like point versus point where
it's like I'm this character that like
I'm the producer but that's a character
too and it's like all right we're gonna
do a debate you're going to host the
debate so here's what we're gonna like
everything's very mapped out yet I mean
so it's there's nothing where it's like
oh man you know this happened with my
dog or like just some normal story right
um so yeah that I I I kind of Miss that
right yeah a lot a lot comes with your
shows though what lot comes with them
okay and I feel like has and here's my
question for you has everyone else you
podcasted with on a microphone showed up
talked and left is that is that your
relationship with every other person
like left in terms of what no no they
they show up they do the show they talk
they leave and that is the end of that
is the end of their episode and even
when they show do they like did anyone
else do research beforehand did anyone
else edit did anyone else post the
episode no no it was nothing like that
for anyone else so you know right that's
a little different okay in the end of
its an air it was a different scenario
yeah completely but it was like where
where you came from what you you know
when I met you yours ah glossary yeah fo
sho mm-hmm and I was like hey I like to
have a female on she'll watch come on
you came out once it was a lot of fun I
brought you on and we grew it and it
grew and I felt like it grew I I feel
like I feel like my early years of the
show handicap to show
people never understood it the problem
with the whole naughty show brand was I
let people define it as an adult porn
star show and it wasn't that it was like
just like chaos like I love the chaos of
it and there are episodes of that show
that we're so [__] good right and I
miss that and there's something else I
want to say about the show that I feel
like you never get credit for at all and
you should especially in this climate
with this election and everything
because here's something I need every
listener to know if you're reading
tweets from people in LA I need you to
understand they're all full of [__] the
everyone's full of [__] here okay you
have to understand that that's not a dig
on Tripoli at all because what I'm gonna
say is with the naughty show show me
another podcast that had as many female
guests that had as many gay or trans
guests that had as many diverse guests
as your show did yeah there isn't one we
were the best like I people going like
that's why is this show [__] huge
like I used to listen to him like this
thing is humming with gas like there was
a [__] way of everybody operating and
I Know Nothings one hundred percent you
know we could never get is the joe rogan
approval that was the thing he always
said he was come on and he never came I
and he would never give us the this is
what I like and I just felt it was good
I enjoyed the show I enjoy doing the
show our show and we were at playboy was
[__] mastery people I love my
favorite thing with do was the watch
people walk into the room and just see
that do you like what the [__] is this
cuz it was in sane corporate yeah you
got a house like that so yes to even get
to us yeah we were the best thing on
that show I'm rational and she and I
talked about that too and the dude who
was the GM at the time and I could say
his name ran playboy radio into the
ground wouldn't listen to us but I miss
that show I just I miss all that i
missed the chaos of that I I still to
this day try
find a way to do something on the level
of that I enjoyed working with you Vicki
I really did at the end for whatever
reason maybe cuz we were 200 shows in
there was a specific thing that happened
for me there was a very specific thing
that happened that made me want to leave
okay and and what what and I'm crime and
and as soon as it was said to me I
didn't want to do the show anymore it
wasn't by you it was about you it was
about how you it was it was one of your
good friends telling me all you do is
complain about me it was in a very
lengthy very well I know who it is I
know you know who it is and he told you
a lot of [__] about me yeah and that
wasn't true Vicki the notion that wasn't
true and I had this but it's hard to
shake that because it's almost like why
would you be sabotaging your friend
because he I'm not gonna say his name
cuz people are gonna flip the [__] out
but this guy is the reason why I don't
work with Brogan anymore cuz what he
told you is what he told a bunch of
people that wasn't [__] true and that
even if it was true and it's like I'm
gonna be honest with you it's why I
don't work with the podcast I kind of
started after i worked with you because
once again somebody i helped in my life
has gone out of his way to tell secrets
that were told under the umbrella of
treatment and friendship and support to
tell people to try to destroy me and and
he did it and he lied he lied he lied
and the old I don't wanna get that I
can't get into because it will bring up
a whole motion of something that I have
going on my life that I need to keep
going but I will tell you this I was not
complaining about you anymore than you
would complain about somebody when you
were like working together on something
and they want to do something their way
and you want to do your wife right it's
just the natural butting heads but a
main thing and and also it was the
situation that we were in it was the way
I was the way I was dressed I mean there
was a lot of it was at a live naughty
show and now this is almost three years
into this podcast where and this
is another how eunice i said how you
dressed no no how I was dressed where
I'm going to this live thing that has
the same name as the podcast I've been
on for years yet I'm not a part of it
whatsoever I'm hidden in the back but
I'm wearing like a 70 [__] dollar
dress in seventy dollars shoes I said
all this [__] money to look the way I
do to be hidden in a back room right and
so when you're in that situation in this
outfit and the things that were being
said to me was just like in my head that
was that um and we were about to do the
200 yeah and I thought after the 200
that's gonna be that and I showed up to
the 200 same way dressed up brought the
cake um and that's when Dave Anthony
asked us to do the podcast festival and
I said well I'm not [__] leave now
we're gonna do this [__] rest of all
now which I think I'm banned from for
some reason really I think excel I think
it's an impression I thought that maybe
cuz of what Eddie if did onstage he
might be back nothing to do with it oh
hey sounds just like this is crazy oh
that's right you were on today i forgot
anywhere on spot I love those guys from
the podcast I just feel that that's too
much pressure for me to do a [__] I just
felt and you guys played mind games with
me on that one to your tell me oh yeah
yeah yeahs person yes I was funny I was
really funny haha here's why I have to
say to all that the reason I I tried to
get you guys up into that show anyway i
could write well people don't understand
about the naughty show at that time when
it was cooking with gas was that it was
the deepest waters I've ever seen
anybody do and then throw anybody just
out there is what it would say it would
jump in rough right and I didn't have
enough I'm listen just work what you did
have enough stage time to the other I
never asked for stand-up on the naughty
show and I never would but there's a
difference between you also did a show
where literally people karaoke and I
think I could have handled a karaoke
song I'm gonna know Josh do it again
absolutely yes I'd love to do it will be
I would like to just do your own wrapper
no no no I want to do the thing you're
in everyone else did I'm a really
reasonable guy I will tell you why I got
hurt this is the we're spot thank god
this is happening I've I even though we
haven't tougher I wish you nothing but
love I consider you a friend even though
I don't talk to you as much because it
got weird I love you and I love Gareth
and I would want nothing more than for
you to do what you're doing now and what
he's doing now I was so happy for you
I've always been like can I help people
who i think are talented go find what
they want to do in life right and I've
always done that I've always found
diamonds in the rough I've done it a
thousand times I keep and I'll keep
doing because I like help because I
realize when you're on the outside not
that I'm on the inside you know I just
did some [__] Comedy Central and I saw
what the inside is and now I don't live
in that world I by [__] flew up
touched it hey [__] you came back down
and you know this party is still going i
got a lot of [__] great going on but i
understand what's be like way on the
outsiders and I like to take people
that's why I'm like who's this chick
that [__] called in and wanted to be
on the show and I know that you and red
bam bum Teddy and there was like I can I
guess I like him I don't I family band
will decree is a wonderful dude who ran
[__] crazy and he is his dude I love him
to death and I wish him number love
either so I got weird and why I did the
podcast and maybe I got weird with you
more than I got weird with Gareth and I
didn't really get weird with Garrett's
at all but I thought it would seem like
at all like that you and I bumped heads
were two things you and I would [__]
about and this is like and I'm this is
not don't take this as attack attack
attack this is me like let's talk about
this throne ear and then go back to
being friends in whatever capacity that
means right right okay yes like like i
like you i don't know i don't like it at
all I didn't really hurt my feelings but
I completely
expected it I completely expected it and
I even told you I was afraid of it and
you said I was crazy but I was like the
minute I don't do things for you you're
not gonna talk to us not what happened
at all that is how I owe you why please
do I what I and all happen okay I would
love to know what you thought happened
okay first of all the Dalek right I
couldn't be happier for get interesting
I couldn't be happier for Gareth Pete
you know I get my balls busted by BL
magical that Dave Anthony stole Gareth
from me and I'm like that's not true at
all i don't think that but it's not true
at all i want nothing but Gareth Gareth
should be the biggest comic in the world
I've always loved Gareth right but like
that thing happened and nobody told me
anything was going on nobody even said
oh yeah Dave Anthony wants to do a show
Garrett I've been like [__] yeah like it
happened and like nobody told me
anything was happening to the point
where I'm like I don't even get like not
even I cuz I don't care I like I'm happy
for him I knew there was like a window
for him to slide in and do big things
which ended up [__] happening but I
wanted somebody that I like why did
anyone even bring it up like uh you know
Dave Anthony wants to show again oh [__]
yeah cool I the problem with Dave
Anthony because I felt Dave Anthony
never had any respect for me or what I
did and there was a discount of what we
were doing because we had occasionally a
chick who want to get naked but with a
great of clowns on a [__] [__] right
which to me is [__] gold but
everybody else thought it was [__]
weird the episode is gold dude but
anyways the fact that was the 200 yes
thank go that was the 200 but nobody
ever told me anything at all and it just
made me feel like there was like oh my
the who my dad a mine [__] is there
is there something coming off like it's
being like some weird behind the door
[__] and i like it just hurt my feelings
at No 1 because I wasn't involved I'm
not involved with that show at all yeah
but you knew it was going down yeah but
I think we'd like promoted it on the
show and everything not till after it
happened but why would that be on me to
say anything because it wasn't just it
was still on Garrett too and I just
like I don't know why anybody wouldn't
tell me right but you've had Gareth on
many times in the past two years because
this show and the other one one hundred
percent right one hundred percent ok and
here but this is what we're talking
about right so then so then what also
hurt my feelings was that you not used
to [__] so much about playboy radio
[__] oh oh oh let's go here but yeah
all the time about playboy radio yeah
and then a week after our show you have
your own show on Playboy Radio I'm so
glad you brought this up cuz I almost
forgot about it until you mentioned
playboy radio before yeah okay this is
what happened I did not get my own show
on Playboy Radio that's not what
happened at all Rick our engineer yes he
thought I was great he never he never
saw anyone out of all the shows they
made no one ever showed up as prepared
as us and brought in guess they did all
you know we did so much we should have
been huge yes and and they probably
should have marketed it differently well
they should've gave they thought he
should have done what they're doing now
but even though it's dead is they
started too late they started [__]
live streaming it and I'm like that's
what you should have been doing from the
start right the audio for free pave a
dollar a month for the [__] live
stream I had no intention to ever set
foot in that building again ever um this
is what happened Rick contacted me and
said that there's a show called just for
the articles i knew the host this guy
Joel I knew him already um and that he
needs a co-host right um this was a job
they were gonna pay yeah top ten [__]
dot but wait it gets better ten [__]
dollars good to me at least breaks even
the gas to burn I did it um but that I
was after them paying me I'm care if
it's a dollar it's the point you're
[__] paying me now I get it and to
get that [__] card for the elevator
which we should have had we should have
been fine this was my [__] you with them
right what this wasn't involved either
right so here's what happened so I go on
like all right well let's let me see
what happens
like it's a closer let me let me go on
it's like a trial run so um there was
really never any guests and the other
guy pretty much did everything and it's
just like I'm they're like oh my my
control sweet tender here's my here's my
two cents but there was no ten bucks so
at first I say to the host I'm like are
you know are they paying you are you
getting paid for this yes he is getting
paid he had at that point co-hosted 12
episodes on Playboy Radio I had produced
a hundred and twenty episodes and
co-hosted a playboy radio so now this
comic and a comic should always be taken
we should be a line not that I'm a comic
but you understand what I'm saying tell
me we should stick with talent right you
don't tell me to hold my truck well my
foot all right too especially cuz you
know who right I'm talking about right
so um 4 4 episode you know he's like let
me just make sure like you know um like
let's just do a few of these and then
we'll say something and then and then
you know four episodes turns into eight
episodes ice and these were told us they
were gonna give us ten dollars a show
for the night show yeah I never saw a
dollar they never gave us anything what
are you putting on elevators nothing
nothing ever he [__] it up that guy
and we won't say his name destroyed that
brand ran it into the ground you know
and it's just like what I dealt with in
Vegas right now just it's amazing to me
the people get the opportunities or the
lease equipped to deal with the
opportunities and they and they jump
over dollars to make dimes I was
convinced the [__] Playboy
playboyplus was just strictly to a loss
leader a tax write-off too I mean to
pull them off of Sirius radio right is
that was the fatal blow because I do
with vivid video but back to what we're
talking oh come on you know for like
fifty six minutes to be able to be like
I'm on serious serious example that you
would don't feel they owe me or whatever
yeah yeah you'd say anything jus just
roll into do that show just to say I'm
on Syria yeah even though you know how
much clout does that even have anymore
but it would have meant something to me
it would mean something that grows and
grows girls but the point was that
that's why I got weird and my feelings
were hurt and and that's hilarious cuz
that was literally 10 or 11 weeks but
you know it's why did he had episodes
and I was like and I lit her you know
how I but you know I didn't go anyway
were like he was just he got so angry at
us for no [__] reason he's like you
guys got paid for the [__] studio I'm
like you run our show 17 times a [__]
yak I'm not paying for jrs their
schedule at one point and this is when
they were people they were paid
subscribers I went through and counted
every time slot eleven percent of their
airtime was our show eleven percent yes
cuz we were the best show and we were
cooking with gas except me Jason Rosso
every day they'd run it wouldn't let it
when he just wanted to talk about
banging kids oh yeah we can't run this
thing they pulled it off the gates and
rouse is just such a weird [__] dude
right so anyways that's why my family my
love him I love him well that's
hilarious so well I'll on discuss it
with you I i miss that we're not friends
no so that's why I want this Cup Eddie
you can now go off on anything you would
like to go okay um well a main thing to
me because yes you're describing the
naughty show live and you're describing
the deep waters and you're describing
what it's like I understand that but
what you need to understand my objective
to do a pocket i don't i'm not trying to
do stand up and sell tickets for stand
up I want the podcast the live podcast
to be the thing that tours you are never
going to want to do that you're a
headliner you make that money already
you have that audience already I I have
no desire to come on here and be like
come see me at this play because I'm not
playing at this place I want to do if
you rat I want to do the live show right
but the rapping nuts that's another
thing that I didn't just wake up and
have that I've been able to do that the
whole time right you know you got the
hills yeah I knew it well I understood
that I understood that I just knew that
our numbers were
something where if we won the road it
wasn't going to be packed I was trying
to figure out how to [__] pack it how
to move a circus around and make it
cost-effective and that's all was I
don't know why we didn't translate more
I know later on I learned that people
just want simple and we were [__] a
sea of chaos yes and I also think the
fact that we were on the west coast
compared to the east coast we were an
East Coast show we would have blown the
[__] up but on the west coast we were a
front of their [__] progressivism and
they we we didn't fit into what they
thought [__] liberalism of being
liberal is and you can just like you
said we had everybody on our show every
make every style every sexual preference
as long it was legal we would have you
on and we would discuss it and I still
to this day think it was way ahead of
its time and I should start releasing
some of those olds old episodes see if
we can get that going but that all i
want to say as I've always liked you I
don't like that we are not friends
anymore we talked a lot all the time I
would love to get back I don't either
but by not talking to me afterwards it
completely validated to me everything I
was told that upset me in the first
place you know when I did your final
Helen you were very combative I felt
like you came at me with a lot of pain
that can you have estas you first of all
I didn't want to end the podcast I just
didn't want to do it anymore I I don't
understand so many people you know red
red band tebow these people come and go
Gareth everybody comes and goes you
still do the naughty show why am I so
connected to it that we have to end the
whole show because I did the whole show
because I felt like we had talked about
everything that I had felt that people
made their ideas about that podcast
right now that they weren't going to
[__] find it and [__] listen to it
because they'd rather listen to just
whatever weird [__] this guy or that guy
was doing it that people made a decision
on it and we'd investigate all the
[__] we've talked all
swingers we've met with all the [__]
porn stars we met with all the weed
people we met with all the drug people
we met with all the witches we met with
a [__] dominatrix we met with
everybody and that weird just like the
team at God together and want to try
something else hmmm that's why it ended
it didn't end because i didn't know in
version of the show ending though that
what we're gonna quit and only and go
anywhere and then what i was gonna do it
on my own yeah well not on your own but
with whoever which seems like is what
happened i bought our feed for some
reason the reason I what other doing the
feed is that cuz i do want anyone to
steal the naughty show name and do it as
a podcast mm-hmm ok i don't know but the
seed would have existed either way I I
mean if yeah I don't we stopped it
because everybody scumbags there's so
many [__] desperate people that if we
stop doing the feed we stopped it
meaning no more episodes wanna see
people like all that shows done we can
start our own version and then it would
be a naughty show version of someone
else doing it here's another really
weird thing that happened because to me
no matter what no matter what I do or
Gareth or anyone else that's your feet
that's yours so you can do whatever you
want with it if I leave what's weird to
me is there someone to stroll in as the
new co-host who I barely know at all who
unfollowed me but he was as my feed that
I built for [__] years like all those
reviews here you go who unfollowed you
Vicky Vicky I had I have no issue with
no issue at all but something made this
guy unfollow me which I'm just saying to
me that would be like if I come join the
show and on follow redban I would never
do that on the naughty show you have not
follow you I'm not talking about the
show I'm not talking about you I'm
talking about the person that rolls up
and and has a ready-made feed of 200
episodes all of a sudden that I thought
we were pretty cool I'm not like best
friends with the person but I thought we
were I need blocked too was it a guy or
girl follow me is a guy yeah
he's crazy I guess yeah so don't get mad
at me for his [__] cuz I gotta fight
with him right now but to me it's like
you don't know me at all but you are
partnered up with this guy every week so
what did this guy say to you about me
for all of a sudden you because even if
you [__] hate everything I say and
you hate every [__] tweet I know
who's in that feat I'm not talking about
you I'm not talking about you I do me
it's like something was said that that
all of a sudden you decide to know
language on witches he's guys own thing
and he'll go through it and he'll [__]
him realize haha you know this is like I
don't know you at all I have no I can't
control what he does and I'm just here
to deal with what happened between us
see if we can go back to being friends
like you don't come by the comedy store
anymore I'll never why never I'm eggs
cuz I'm busy now I did it not like that
and I'm happy where you are I couldn't
be happier for all this stuff you're
doing oh thanks that editing and all
that stuff you started doing with the
naughty show right yeah and you went on
to do great [__] Gareth Reynolds [__]
started on a naughty show doing the
[__] naughty show we were the first
one to put my podcast yes now he's on
this huge one yeah everybody seems I've
worked out I'm still [__] grinding
and that's [__] cool right it's all
good but I had nothing to do with the
formation or any kind of secrecy about
the dollop agent became something and it
just was I just had the time got my
feelings hurt that no one even bring it
up yeah hey dude Garrett's gonna do a
podcast Dave great it just seems like it
was up and his running and nobody even
told me and I'm just like I don't know
you know cuz it already existed without
Gareth Dave did it alone so was like
Gareth was a guest and then Gareth was a
guest again and so slowly this thing
morphed yeah this and then washing room
days all be recei and then it slipped in
there mmhmm yeah yeah so that's all I'm
anything I won't see many more hard
feelings there too like what's just way
worse once well I get that and I have no
say in any of that I am no take on that
I don't even I feel like that might have
caused some hard feelings with some
people
on on the walking the room and and again
it's like I had nothing to do with it
like I this is literally my involvement
in this is that I thought it was funny
that Dave Anthony would just be
contrarian to everything we did and that
you and him would fight I thought it was
such a funny dynamic the crazier the
thing was going to be the more I'd want
him on that's literally where my
involvement ends bringing Dave on the
naughty show that's all oh hey Dave if I
thought you had any respect for what I
did I would love I don't care if you
[__] like what I do but the disc I
just fell he discounted everything and
it's is but he kept coming on yeah but
it that's what listen I have no problems
with Dave Anthony and I wish you nothing
but love and success I really don't have
any issues with them but I feel like
there's this whole thing with this
Hollywood elite group where it's just
like they dismiss what we do even though
they love to partake into it because we
have girls coming on half naked all the
somewhere we're [__] disrespecting
them or degreeing that one at the end of
the day whether we like them or not
there is then what they're gonna do yes
and it's just like instead like we let
them have fun and laughs and at the end
they're like I loved doing the show
thank you so much and like when they go
back they go back to this [__] [__]
ass world and like it's just it goes
back to your whole thing about these
being honest with like oh we you know
with having everybody on and be the only
people really do that yes and it goes
back to the hypocrisy of this town that
I see yes that you know this town like
talks a big talk but behind their back
they don't like these people they don't
like those people they all live in gated
communities please know that yeah please
knows what adam crow says about
Hollywood it's lovely oh yeah they all
sit there like shave the plant than
their driving fox-like ha mercy and
that's it like I walked the walk and I
like everything at you see people doing
in stamp now I was doing ten years ago
and it's just like and you know it's
like the same thing with comedy central
who I love to death i'm thankful to work
with them but when they're like we don't
like you and then they give the naughty
show basically to Nikki Glaser and
you're like why didn't it work out who
Nikki losers great well how about to
like there's there's someone
that I see like almost every night where
it's like all they're tweeting about
it's just you would think wow this guy's
such a feminist such a feminist and it's
like hey bro didn't you produce the show
that took an actual bit from the naughty
show and put it on [__] television
yeah yeah yeah because I remember that
happening but one hundred percent no one
else seems no one else seemed to notice
that now a [__] how much stuff happened
on the note naughty show that people
went and put on TV and then gave us no
credit for it whatsoever and and just so
anyone listening if you think I'm being
crazy and it's parallel thinking it's
not parallel thinking when it's
literally the people who called us nasca
schuco the [__] was and they're like
oh yeah we'll get us on than they did
and that's why Brody and I had a big
fight oh well okay I wall he's not the
twitter feed i was talking about Oh make
sure I had a different one right
different one ah and if there is any
[__] fault I'm on me so real quick we
got wrap it up thoughts on Trump Jersey
girl thoughts on Trump I think it's
hilarious I think it's great i find my
last night's like I hate Trump everyone
claps I go now for the reason you hate
you hate your magazine beat Hillary I
can't Yuri you guys [__] up Hillary's
a Sith Lord and she couldn't be in the
[__] ass clown I'm s what happened I
predicted it this is the third
presidential election that I've
predicted accurately before the Iowa
caucus I knew he was gonna win the first
debate when he was in the middle I was
like he's gonna win the whole thing
watch and everyone acted like I was
crazy everyone acted like I was an idiot
and it's like I really see when you see
all these post to if you think this on
phone me if you think this unfriend me
well that's what creates this idea that
you're running away with this election
cuz you're not at all you live in echo
chamber to me it's like I can't believe
anyone was surprised you not have eyes
did you not turn the television on you
see you saw two guys in the primaries
with massive crowds Bernie and Trump
yeah right then all of a sudden Bernie's
out of it so then it's Trump torn Trump
TV 24 seven tens of thousands of people
every day all over the place and all
these sweet sausage
late it and she's trying still she's
trying still the flip that she's like
I'm joined the [__] the recon I just
don't know you started it man you you
you guys see there are you at all in the
conspiracy theories are you not a
conspiracy theory person totally
probably not but i don't it depends i
don't know i just think there's so much
money i think crimes and like rigging
election as a crime is all drawn by
passion and money yeah and when you look
at an election and you look at Hilary
Clinton she's driven by her desire and
her passion to be the first female
president that's all she wants right I I
wouldn't doubt if you go if someone
listen you can have the pregnancy you
just have to kick kill Chelsea I
wouldn't doubt if the thought would go
through her head for a [__] second if
it would be worth it I think the Chelsea
only exists so they can have these
political careers I think it's like well
we got to marry each other need at least
one kid yeah yeah i'm not i really think
that he's a poon dog she probably eats
box I mean it's just like it's in weird
as [__] man you don't think you're gonna
eat some box dog and there's some i love
the reaction i think they're poking the
bear dude and i think like there is law
and order when everyone agrees to it
this is what I think this is what I
think and I I kind of almost don't
understand why more people aren't seeing
it this way unless they are and no one
wants to say well there's Hollywood
people a knowledge you get to it real
quick that play to the shadow group out
there this weird progressive shadow
group they're like it's like when you
know [__] who are told dicks have
like a tape on their mouth and then it's
like an no on 8 and you're like you're
an [__] says the word [__] all the
time like what are you talking about I
know you don't like gay guys but you're
just you like there's this notion in la
de if you play this little power group
that they're gonna grant you that
[__] audition or fight you to that
[__] group it's like weird sure where
I would hope you know I saw a lot of
poets words like you know if if you see
a woman hug her if you see a black
person tell them that they have they can
be safe with you why would I 35 years
people have known me I need to make a
list of the people that I like you know
who I like [__] anyone do I care
about anything and and like I said I
mean look at look at all of our guests
through the ears and [__] do you think
anything faith wrong you think I give a
[__] where mia isabella pisses at target
yeah I don't care yeah I think it'd be
super weird if she was forced to go into
the urinal next to you since it's a
woman yeah and who he cares what's in
your pants yeah it's so nuts we all pee
sitting down we but I think that in my
head it was like after the primaries
like bye bye bushes and then bye bye
Clinton's haha she's not trying they're
trying to get her daughter to run now
they're like Kardashians he just and he
pushing out you're all over with if you
don't meet somebody new now if Trump
ends up I am we're gonna wrap up Aaron
I've Trump ends up being as devastating
as like the left tries to make you think
which is not gonna happen I'm he's
talking about getting rid of the reserve
it might end quicker than anybody wants
to talk about but if if if he ends up
being as bad as he is there is an
argument that the Clintons are the worst
thing to ever happen to America ever and
I'm not talking like [__] draw a
stock market crashes everything like
like deregulation the banks deregulation
the media [__] free trade and then
giving us the Trump can see like that's
a list of that's a [__] who's who of
murder of this country to the point
where I don't think history will be kind
with to them I think over time when as
the internet keeps growing and that's
why I think you see them Aging's I mean
they are entering their 70s but it's
like right there's a there's a 70s and
then like my grandpa was 70 didn't look
as bad as Clinton does like cleanse like
he feels like he can't sleep cuz he
hears demons coming for his soul all I
was thinking is okay remember watching
Dick Clark every year on rockin Eve
toward the end I was like do you really
want to watch Slick Willy bill clinton
poon hound yeah
kiri right before our eyes over the next
four to eight years it's depressing I do
they got to start eating some spirit
contrasting it's sad have you heard a
pizza gate yes of course thoughts
positive negative no not pausing there
is not too may be true where there's
smoke there's fire true false with her
smoke there's fire um I personally think
false but I would I would never say a
hundred percent false I don't know my
thought is that about is it I feel a
night I appreciate what you're saying
and we're gonna write it up up into men
I appreciate what you're saying I
personally think that to say there's no
way like there's people there's always a
way I'm so people were they they look at
me and then emotionally check out and
they're like I can't believe you're
saying that and like they walk off like
just heartbroken that I would be like
can you say with all honesty that this
is impossible right he's like I'm not
saying it's impossible it's impossible
I'm saying with all the [__] you've seen
this government do and the people in the
government are you saying pedophile ring
is so beyond that when you like you like
the church Penn State also say that the
notion that there might be [__] pizza
shop why not a pizza like what makes a
pizza shop any crazier than a
high-profile d1 [__] football program
or your local church how is it beat shop
any different than your local church so
to say that there's no way it's
happening is my ways just because I
don't think it's this pizzeria or these
or you're showing me an email where I
feel like they're clearly describing a
pool party those are people that know
each other's kids like the evidence I've
seen this is so flimsy but the idea that
something [__] up in DC could never
happen yeah of course it could you know
what it is everywhere is that we
transmit our feelings of what we would
do and how we would handle it we could
be involved with that to these
politicians who I think you're sickening
so I'm gonna project that well someone
does it are gonna be against the law we
went up to worry there'd be no to catch
a predator in England age highest levels
of their government has been busted with
this radio DJ I can't remember his name
got busted
charities for children and at the
charities he would [__] these kids over
and it's horrible look into it [__]
jam it yeah I mean the guy had some
plays [__] kids but you can't believe
that [__] comet ping pong is doing
this and with that Vicki I hope that in
some weird way I feel like we could do a
whole just our on the discussion oh I
know it's just therapy ah I just want to
say I'm so happy like new podcast
hashing it out with Sam Tripoli and it
out but like I'm smoking hash in the
picture well I'm so happy that you're
doing well I'm so happy that you're
making good money doing stuff that that
you went on to do it I'm glad Garrett's
doing bath I would like to do a once in
a wild naughty show don't know if you're
open to that a naughty show podcast
feeling out get back to getting weird
once in a while no I like you law I'm
sorry we haven't been each other's lives
and I wish we could go back to that in
some form I will randomly call you if
you'd like to talk I would love to toss
you called me every day for like three
years you know just what i called and
talked it was obviously we both have
hurt feelings about it and that's what
this is about just let's move on life's
too short ok alright alright so a very
thing but I do love you Vicky and I'm
thankful that you came and do the show
and I hope you had fun and hope you guys
enjoyed ah say space and we will see you
next week take care everybody playing
song i'm too lazy